In the book,
bored and brilliant rediscovering the lost art of spacing out man minutiae is
on,
explains the connection between board,
I mean being unplugged and how that state of mind can ignite original thinking
through Ah,
through reviews with scientists,
famous artists and regular people.
Some roadie explains by putting a greater emphasis on doing nothing is vital and
age of constant notifications and digital distractions.
She explores how we can harness boredom's hidden benefits to become our most
productive selves.
Bored and brilliant.
It's permission to unplug.
Please welcome the author and host of the podcast note to self is I'm already,
thank you so much.
Right on.
Thank you guys.
Thanks for being patient with me and hanging out.
I don't know,
like you rush off to meetings at Google or is evolved enough that you don't have
to do that.
I don't know.
Um,
so I'm just going to play you a little video just to get a sense of,
um,
what I've been working on for the last couple of years.
Let's see if it plays.
Okay.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to tell you about how this book came to be.
Um,
cause it's kind of unusual.
I think it's truly the first,
and this is a mouthful,
the first podcast crowdsourced project to be turned into a book.
I'm going to take that title for myself.
I know everyone's been clamoring for it,
but I'm going to take it.
Um,
so I'm going to tell you about the genesis of it.
I'm gonna play you a little bit of audio,
some of the stuff that I've been making,
cause it's all really comes down to the podcast that I've been making.
And then I'm going to tell you about the book tour that I've been on for the
last two weeks because it's been sort of my own little focus group across the
country.
And it's been fascinating to hear the people who've come out to spend time with
me and what's on their minds,
which I think is interesting to all of us making the stuff that they use.
Um,
so if you don't know what my podcast is called,
note to self,
it's part of New York public radio.
Um,
I started out as a hardcore journalist.
I was with the BBC,
I was with Reuters.
Um,
and my,
my job was flying around the world for a long time and covering hotspots.
And then once I had kids,
I was really more covering business and tech.
Um,
and then I got into podcasting and I sort of realized that my job had changed.
It was less about reporting on the developments that was happening at companies
like yours,
but really more that as a podcast,
there was an intimacy that was there with my community that people,
when you listen,
there was this sense that we were talking to each other,
there was conversation and that what people really wanted was some help.
They were feeling as though the world was moving at a accelerating pace and they
felt unmoored by it.
Because as you know,
technology is changing the way that we fall in love,
the way that we parent,
the way that we work,
everything.
And people sort of didn't know how to handle it.
And so that's what note to self really evolved into.
Um,
and so one of the things that I did was a project,
um,
an interactive project that was called the bored and brilliant project,
the lost art of,
of spacing out.
And this was in 2015 and the genesis of this was actually that the podcast,
you know,
it was doing well,
it was 2014 podcasting was starting to take off,
which was super exciting for me.
And I was,
I dunno,
I'd give us like a B plus a minus.
And I had this moment where I was like,
okay,
how am I going to step up my game?
It was kind of a cliched moment to have,
um,
how am I going to come up with better ideas?
And I had this feeling like,
well,
when was the last time that I did come up with my best ideas?
And it was such a cliche.
It was like,
Oh,
when I'm driving in the car and staring out the window,
I was never bored,
is what I realized.
I realized that all the cracks in my day when I was waiting to get a cup of
coffee or I was waiting to get on the subway or to pick up my kids,
all those little moments when I used to sort of be spacing out or thinking
things through or whatever,
I now was looking,
somebody did leave their phone up here.
I was looking at this thing and I guess I was like,
well,
I guess never being bored.
Is that a good thing?
I mean,
I guess it's a good thing.
That's what they tell us.
Only boring people get bored,
right?
But then I started to wonder like,
well,
what actually happens in our brains when we get bored?
Or more importantly,
what could be happening to all of us if we never get bored ever again if we
don't,
uh,
experience this human state that has,
I think,
been with,
with us for Millennia.
And so I sort of reached out to my listeners and I was like,
are you guys thinking about this too?
Are you wondering how your smartphones or changing your thinking patterns,
um,
would you be interested in?
Maybe,
I dunno what's like doing a week of experiments where we see that if we changed
our smartphone habits,
how it would affect our thinking.
And I thought like a couple hundred people would sign up to play with me for a
week.
And um,
and within 48 hours,
20,000 people signed up and I was like,
Whoa,
okay.
This is a thing.
A lot of people are feeling this.
People like Corrine.
Hi,
my name is Caryn.
I am made New Yorker,
born and raised and was desperate for this board at brilliant challenge.
It's perfect.
I needed it.
Um,
I've definitely developed some compulsion's for Facebook,
Instagram,
checking the news,
checking emails,
replying to email right away,
texting,
hunting for funny emojis.
Just,
I just need a break from my phone because I'm not sure that these activities
really add all that much value to my life and they certainly take up a lot of my
time.
Okay.
So Caren and I for one week in 2015 every morning we woke up and we put out a
little podcast that explained the neuroscience of what is going on in your brain
when you actually get bored.
It describes some of the technologies design in terms of getting our attention
and how we use it.
And it asks them to do a very small behavior change,
something to try that day just to see what would happen and then report back to
us.
Um,
and so what we learned,
and I found out that this is fascinating,
we are at an extraordinary moment when it comes to understanding what happens in
the brain when the mind wanders.
It's like it's really hot news and neuroscience.
So it turns out that when you get bored,
you ignite a brain network in your brain called the default mode.
And in the default mode,
we have our most original thoughts.
We do our most creative thinking.
We take two seemingly disparate ideas,
we smashed them together and create a new idea.
And we do something that I had never heard of before called autobiographical
planning.
This is where you look back at your previous,
at the earlier life that you've had,
and you take note of the highs and the lows and you build a personal narrative
and then decide,
you know,
where am I going to go from here?
What are my goals?
And you set the steps that you need to reach those.
And um,
so kind of important stuff that is going on in your brain.
Um,
and it also turns out that a decade ago we shifted our attention at work about
every three minutes and now we're shifting our attention at work every 45
seconds.
I found this amazing researcher,
her name is Dr Gloria Mark.
She's a professor of informatics at UC Irvine.
And she told me that the average person is switching tasks at work 566 times a
day.
So what I asked Gloria was,
I said,
is it because the technology has been designed to take our attention and get us
switching like that,
or is this just a human thing that if it wasn't the technology,
we'd be distracted by something else?
And here was her answer.
So I think it was a combination.
One thing that we've found is that there's actually a physiological reasons that
can explain why people shift their attention so rapidly.
So we find though when people are stressed,
they tend to shift their attention more avidly.
We also found,
strangely enough,
the shorter amount of sleep that a person gets,
the more likely they are to check Facebook.
We're in this vicious habitual cycle.
I mean,
I thought that was hilarious and made complete and utter sense because when I am
tired at night,
that is when I find myself going like this on my phone and not even looking at
whatever it is that I thought I was looking for.
And of course,
I mean I think that this has been a wake up call for a lot of Americans.
This idea that if the product is free,
then you are the product and we're seeing that conversation be more and more
prevalent and more mainstream.
Um,
so really the most gratifying,
um,
I found was that a lot of classrooms across the country did the bored and
brilliant project,
uh,
mostly high schools and freshmen college kids.
And,
and here's how I put it in the book,
talking,
listening,
eye contact,
downtime,
responsiveness and yes,
boredom are all activities that now need to actively be put into practice.
It's not the digital natives don't feel or know these things,
it's just that they don't get prioritized and so we must name schedule and
celebrate them.
Whether it's the effect that reading on screen has on our attention spans or
video game play has on socio ability or taking photos has on memory.
We're living in an age of self experimentation.
Technology is evolving faster than researchers can study it.
Science can't keep up,
which is why we need a new interdisciplinary approach like the one we could
offer with bored and brilliant research.
Now Neves needs to move out of the lab because life is the new lab.
So just in case you think like it's not a detox.
I absolutely refuse to use that word because I don't think it's a binary,
it's not on or off.
Right.
I think what we're finding is that users need to understand how it fits into
their lives and turn their phones from what had become task.
Mack masters back into tools that actually improve their lives.
And right now they're not feeling like there are,
a lot of them are feeling like they're not there yet.
Um,
so,
and I just want to play you a clip.
So one of the days that we asked we had was called delete that app where we
asked people to,
uh,
take the APP that was driving them bonkers,
bananas off their phone just for the day.
You know,
you don't have to quit it,
whatever.
Just delete that off your phone so it's not following you around.
And I want to play you a clip from a listener named Liam who did the original
product,
uh,
project.
This is Leon in Los Angeles and I deleted Twitter,
Facebook,
Instagram,
Tumblr,
snapchat,
and vine from my phone in one fell swoop.
And it was kind of an embarrassingly emotional experience at first.
It felt weirdly loneliness to look at that lock screen with no new notifications
on it.
But I really like deciding for myself when to think about we're access my social
networks,
not giving my phone the power to decide that for me.
So thank you.
I Love Liam.
He's such an extremist,
right?
He's like,
I'm taking them all off.
All of them.
Okay.
So people took all kinds of things off.
They took social media off,
they took games,
some people took news off.
If you've got a headline,
refreshing habit.
Um,
but I will say the other thing that we did during the original product,
uh,
project was that we partnered with two different apps.
Um,
and I did get some pushback on that.
People were like,
wait,
you're telling us to download certain apps in order to take apps off?
I was,
look,
we got to meet people where they are.
So,
um,
moment was for the iPhone break free was for android.
And what they did was measure how many minutes a day they were on their phone
and how many pickups day they were on their phone.
So we were able to have,
um,
thousands of people contributing their data back to us and we were able to
measure which days,
uh,
activities were more effective and which ones sort of we're not.
So the first time around in 2015,
I was totally winging it.
I just made every,
all the experiments up.
I was like,
I don't know,
let's try this.
But what we were able to do is go back and look at all the data and the stories
and codify it into what is now the book.
Of course.
Um,
so in the end we had 20,000 people that one week,
all 50 states,
we measured that 90% of them cut down on their phone time,
which,
you know,
I kind of feel like,
okay,
that's great.
But really the more important thing was that 70% felt as though they had more
time to just think,
which,
I mean it's,
I just did a tedtalk.
Um,
and they were like,
yeah,
so I don't know,
is that gonna be enough that like your messages that people need to think?
I was like shocking.
Right?
Liam got back in touch,
uh,
two weeks ago because I did a shout out to my listeners and I was like,
do any of you remember the project that we did in 2015 I've got this book coming
out.
They totally remembered.
Um,
Liam got back to me and he said,
actually,
I never put the apps on my phone.
After that week,
I just decided that I liked things better without them.
So here's what he told me.
I'm currently on an incredible trip to Europe and I've stayed off Facebook this
whole time.
Every time I pound you're posting a photo from my adventures,
I think about how I keep checking to.
He liked it and I think about how seeing other people's adventures on Facebook
nine times out of 10 and doesn't making me feel depressed by comparing my life
to my perception of theirs.
There's something about sharing my life very sparingly now that makes my
experience a little richer and more introspective.
So I was like,
okay,
Liam's the extremist.
Of course he's going to be all dramatic.
He's an actor in la by the way,
so of course there's drama there,
but it turns out a lot of people made changes that stuck with them.
Okay,
note to self.
My name is Naomi and I did the bored and brilliant projects back in 2015.
One thing I did was delete the Facebook app on my phone and two years later I
still don't have it.
And you send,
they studied the use meals as my boy them tights.
It feels a little uncomfortable,
but I think letting my thoughts run though is important to take charge of my
life.
I leave the phone downstairs and turned off and when I go on walks with my wife,
I don't even bring it.
I deleted the Instagram APP because I was noticing every time I logged on I
would get kind of a stomach ache,
like that anxiety stomach gig.
And I thought,
I don't need this as a time waster and it doesn't bring me joy.
So I'm deleting it.
But I just want to tell you one of my favorite stories.
This is from Vanessa in Wisconsin.
So the bored and brilliant project happened.
She was going through a breakup.
She had to decide what she was going to do about the farm that she owned with
her partner.
Um,
she did the project and then at the end she decided that she bought her,
they broke up,
she bought the farm full of outright and then decided that she needed to do
something with the farm for the community.
So she renamed it,
make time farm.
And now,
once a month she has a day where she invites people to come and just kind of
hang out.
There's a basket if they want to put their phone in their people,
bring their sewing machine there.
Watercolor,
they do all kinds of things.
They nap.
I would like to go to Vanessa's farm and take a nap.
That would be nice.
They also like think about like goal setting and things like that.
So Vanessa sort of decided that this was something that she wanted to have in
her life and for the community,
which was great.
Um,
and so now with the book,
I am reaching a whole different category of people who,
um,
it's interesting.
What kind of reactions?
Some people are podcasts,
people who know the show and know sort of the things that we talk about on the
show,
which are a lot of ethics related.
Um,
and other people have never heard of it at all,
but this is something that's sort of been on their mind and they want to
explore.
Um,
so I'm going around the country and I'm having lots of fun and I'm making people
take selfies because as I said,
this is not an all or nothing sort of thing.
There are moms going out drinking before they come to hang out with me,
which has been great.
And I thought this review,
it's really funny that this could do for unplugging what Marie Kondo is the life
changing magic of tiding up did for decluttering.
Um,
I mean,
I love that.
That would be great if I was as big as Marie Kondo.
But to me what's more interesting is really since I finished writing this book,
um,
a lot has changed in this country.
It is really hard not to continually refresh the headlines or Twitter just asked
the president.
Um,
but I think perhaps it's time for us to collectively rethink some of our tech
habits.
Because the other thing that happens when you ignite the default mode is you do
empathy.
You imagine what other people around you are thinking and how they're feeling.
And if there is one thing this country could use right now is a little empathy,
um,
and some creative problem solving to sort of find solutions to some huge
economic,
racial and environmental issues.
And so I think particularly for young people to understand that a quickness
isn't necessarily a virtue.
Um,
or as the ex checker of the Bank of England said,
he's worried that quick thinking could make for slow growth.
So this is not just,
um,
a,
you know,
self-helpy sort of thing.
But I think really an economic thing that we need people to take a minute and
let a mediocre idea that they might want to share.
Just sit on it for a little while,
let it turn into something bigger,
let it turn into big solution.
Um,
which a lot of young people are not used to doing.
so I'm just telling people to get bored.
That's all I want them to do on this big a book tour that I'm on right now.
And,
um,
you heard about the podcast,
you've heard about my listeners experience some of the new people that I'm
meeting and I would love to talk to you guys because you're the first tech
company that I've gone to to make this presentation.
So I would love to hear like what your thoughts are on this,
your comments,
any questions,
um,
personal experience.
That would be great.
And thank you for having me.
Great.
Mike over here is open for questions for anyone who would like,
I also love,
I mean,
I'm sure you're all like,
oh my God,
another anti-tech person.
But like,
really,
I really want to hear what you guys think.
One of the people in the book is a Tristan Harris.
Have you heard of,
he was a Google ethicist for a little while and now he's created his own sort
of,
I'm starting to think about ways that the tech could build in ways of making
people communicate more.
Um,
sort of in tune with sending expectations of other people.
So I'd love to know what you guys think.
Hi.
Okay.
So I would be,
I'd be curious to know how much this affects someone's work life balance if
they're checking their work email and other work applications on the phone.
And I wondered if you looked into that.
Um,
definitely.
Yeah.
So,
um,
there's one chapter in particularly in particular focused
on workplace reasons because what I hear from a lot of people who come to these
events as they're like,
well,
I work in social media.
How am I supposed to take time off?
Um,
so from a personal perspective,
I think having in the book,
I really tried to lay out how,
um,
being productive we have to reimagine what being productive is.
So for my,
in my own personal,
uh,
when I'm riding the subway home,
I used to think like,
great,
this is my time to just jam through email,
right?
Like I'm going to hit it.
But now I realize,
actually,
no,
this is 30 minutes of me where I can actually do some solid thinking about
something that's been bothering me all day long or a work issue that I haven't
had time to sort of really drive into.
So I've had to rethink what productivity actually means and what I'm hoping.
So.
So there's a whole chapter about specifically how we define productivity and
problem solving and um,
and then there's also,
um,
uh,
so,
so the,
the challenge that day is to take a vacation,
which is to reset the expectations of the people who are hoping to hear from
you.
Right?
Because I think that's the other thing that we've found is that we're,
when we're waiting in line for coffee,
you're like,
oh,
this is an opportunity,
these two minutes or an opportunity to show my spouse how I'm thinking of them
or that I'm on top of like,
you know,
what's for dinner or my coworkers that I know that we,
we needed to follow up on x.
Um,
so resetting expectations by setting outgoing messages,
which I think a lot of people don't do.
Um,
and so I tell people like,
you know,
even if it's for a half an hour,
it's if,
if your outgoing message says I'm working on something,
um,
and,
and that's why you're not hearing from me.
It's resetting their expectations and other people are like,
my boss will never accept that.
And I'm like,
okay,
so you have a stomach virus for one hour.
You know what I mean?
Like do what you gotta do.
Cause it's really important.
But then the other thing that I've done is I joined a silent workspace.
We're um,
there's no talking,
there's no eating.
So no crinkle crinkle with like,
I love my snacks,
but none of that.
And for me,
like I realized the most important work I do every week is my writing,
right?
So I need,
and I know that I need that three to four hours.
It's really,
I've tried to write the show and last or I've tried to do it while I'm jumping
in and out of meetings.
It doesn't work.
I need the three to four hours.
And so I joined this workspace.
I don't get there more than like once or twice a week,
but I think it's worth it for me.
So my fantasy is that every company has a silent workspace where,
you know,
it's seen as productive that you're going in there and not talk.
Yeah,
right.
We are with clapping in the front.
Wouldn't that be amazing?
Like if you were like,
no,
I've got serious work to do and my,
because I don't know about you guys,
but like in my office,
first of all,
radio people,
oh my God,
they never stopped talking.
And there's a lot of this like,
oh my God,
I'm so sorry.
I'm totally interrupting you.
And then they start talking and you're like,
no,
like I'm,
I'm,
yes,
you were interrupting me.
So that's my big fantasy.
And like Susan Cain,
she's,
I definitely quote her in the book,
the quiet revolution,
but I think we need to codify it and,
and it's not just for introverts.
It's extroverts need to like,
be quiet and do the hard work too.
Um,
so does that,
lots of thoughts.
I think it makes a lot of sense.
Uh,
the,
uh,
one of the things I found was I recently took my corporate account off of my
phones.
I just have my personal account on those benches.
And how's that go?
I,
I was,
um,
I had difficulty with it at first because it was something I was just
constantly,
you just trust him to having their on them on the phone.
But I found that a,
my battery lasts longer on the fund is not constantly updating high volumes of
email be,
it's something where I don't just compulsively start checking the work email and
getting engaged in,
in to the workload related tasks.
I'm kidding.
I'm so guilty.
Like,
I mean,
I always use thinking about my podcast.
It's all I do.
And if it were up to me,
I'd be emailing and pinging my producers all day long and like,
you know,
I gotta like walk the talk here,
right?
So I try to save up and like make my communication with them meaningful and
constructive as opposed to like,
what do you guys think about Yada Yada.
Um,
Gloria mark that wonderful informatics professor.
You guys were like the only audience I think I've ever had that actually knows
what an informatics person is.
By the way.
Um,
she tried out,
was kind of cracked me up.
She tried out a Japanese many Japanese zen garden.
Where is she in an office where everybody had a mini Japanese zen garden.
And depending on the formation of the rocks,
it indicated to your,
um,
coworkers whether you were in deep work or whether you were willing to be in
conversation.
So my team got me a mini zen garden.
It doesn't work,
but,
um,
it looks pretty though.
Um,
but Tristan,
the person that I mentioned,
he was talking about this idea of like,
what if we could have,
um,
Google docs where you had like a pause button that was like,
Hey,
I'm in the middle of working on this.
Give me an I'll pay,
it'll ping you when I'm ready for you to come and look what I do.
Because as a podcast person,
we run on Google docs.
I mean everything is in Google docs and it drives me bananas when I'm in the
middle of writing something.
And I see my producers face show up and like get outs,
I am doing something here,
you know,
but how do you like,
Hey,
can you come back later basically is what I have to say.
So it'd be so nice to like snooze it or something or,
and I think it's resetting expectations.
You know,
one final question about this is are there any companies that you're aware of
that are doing the analytics feedback to the employees so that they are given a
nudge to,
to separate their work life?
Um,
environment?
Yeah,
so the,
the big example that I use is Boston consulting group where they did,
it was part of a study that was done by Leslie Leslie Perlow at Harvard where
they tried different ways of setting up groups where one person was in a group,
um,
was told to take time off,
like specifically.
And they were told to like,
like cook,
hang out with your family.
And they knew that another group member was covering for them.
And BCG had been experiencing really rapid turnover and burnout.
And so they want it to see if this would make a difference in their retention
levels went way up.
Um,
so that's the example I use.
I think there are,
I don't know a ton of people trying it out,
but um,
but I think if we start to think of it as a way to,
you know,
cut back on costs because we don't have to hire as many people deal with the
burnout that so many places are seeing because we're working all the time.
But also think of it as like,
you know,
working smarter,
not necessarily harder.
So thanks for your question.
So I'm also guilty of the,
of,
I call it like micro efficiency where I tried to extract every thing I can at
every minute of the day.
I love that.
Can I use that micro efficiency and a as kind of last year as a way to kind of
help myself,
um,
not do that anymore is a,
I joined the meditation group at Google and they encourage that by donating
money,
mangoes in the book.
Oh really?
Yeah,
totally.
He's been on the
show.
He's awesome.
I asked my question was,
um,
do you do in the course of writing the book,
did you find that meditation also helped with this with increasing creativity
and kind of,
yeah.
So if I pause for a little bit,
it's a different thing.
Um,
meditation ignites in different parts of the brain.
It is completely different than the mind wandering part.
Um,
so the mind wandering thing is when you are doing nothing.
So it could be like repetitive folding of laundry,
um,
or it could be walking to work or something that doesn't require active focus on
what you're doing.
Um,
the idea with meditation is that there's active focus on thinking about nothing,
right?
Or the clearing of the mind.
That is what you are focused on.
And so that is its own thing.
But this is truly letting the mind wandering part goes into daydreaming and it
can also go to some bad places.
I mean,
let's make no mistake,
just because you let your mind wander,
it doesn't mean like,
Holy Shit,
you have the next great startup idea,
right?
It's,
um,
there's a dis dysphoric thinking,
which was a rumination,
which is going to be me tomorrow going over this talk and how some of the
PowerPoint slides fired themselves and how much that annoyed me and thinking it.
And you know,
if only I could go back to Google and give that talk over,
you know,
I'm going to be thinking about that.
Okay.
So that's not good.
Then there's also the distraction kind,
which is people who just ping all over the place when your mind is wandering.
Um,
I'm certainly guilty of that as well.
But then there's the,
the wonderful kind,
which is positive,
constructive mind wandering.
This was a Jerome singer who did some of the most,
the,
the deep,
uh,
pioneering work on mind wandering and that is when we start to do that wonderful
constructive type of mind wandering.
Um,
but teen maintain the guy who you,
I think you're,
um,
referring to who started the Google,
inside yourself.
Of course.
Is that something that like everybody knows about it?
Google or is that like,
yeah,
say that again.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Have any of you done it?
Anyone?
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
So the sense I got is like,
it's relatively popular.
Um,
so he talks about the different kinds of meditation that there are.
And I think if you're getting positive benefits from those and um,
it's,
it's great.
I mean,
no reason not to continue to do it and this would just mind wandering would be a
separate but also equally wonderful time.
Nice.
Cool.
Thanks.
So this idea of kind of default mode and in urological basis for this is really
interesting.
So I'm curious,
I guess,
what is the sort of definition of boredom?
So like for example,
the experience of like walking down a nice trail is very different from the
experience of,
you know,
walking down New York City or yes,
even running versus walking,
if you will,
kind of different.
So I'm curious if there's certain activities or environments that are more
boring than others or matters.
So I got a lot of pushback,
right?
Um,
when I first used the word boredom on the show,
people were like,
can you call it something a little nicer,
please?
Like daydreaming?
And I was like,
no,
actually,
um,
boredom is the perfect word because I think that is really what we're seeing is
that why,
why do we distract ourselves?
Because we feel uncomfortable.
Um,
and if you look at the history of boredom,
it's,
I mean there's a really nerdy chapter on that too,
which is that the word didn't appear until 1853,
Charles Dickens' bleak house boredom and it makes sense,
right?
Industrial Revolution.
People have more free time,
they have time to be bored.
Um,
but if you look back even further,
Kierkegaard preferred the word idol.
Uh,
the French called it on.
We,
uh,
hi.
I'm thinking of other philosophers who described it as this sort of existential
angst that we have.
What,
what is my purpose here on earth?
Heidegger in particular.
Um,
so for me,
using the word bored,
I think there are those of us who find mind wandering.
Wonderful.
Or maybe we used to think it was boring,
but now we think it's great.
I think parents in particular who are,
you never have time to get born like it.
Um,
but I really specifically wanted to use that word because I think some people,
particularly I see this with young people,
think that they can skip straight to the good original thinking stuff.
That there's like an Apple's going to drop on their head and they're going to
have a great idea.
And I feel like,
no,
actually you're going to,
it's going to hurt.
It's going to be painful.
It's going to suck until the good stuff comes.
Um,
I gave the book earlier this summer to a chemistry major,
a student at American University and had him record his experience and you hear
him just like,
oh my God,
I don't want to do this.
I really don't want to do this.
Just really struggling.
I don't recognize this feeling.
Normally I would just look at my phone whenever I have these feelings and then
you get to like day five,
and he goes for this walk in Rock Creek Park and he,
he's like,
I'm just going to do it.
I'm just going to succumb to the mind wandering.
And he comes up with this amazing idea,
um,
related to solar panels and the home town that he grew up in in Puerto Rico,
which has a disproportionate amount of churches that have a lot of roof,
uh,
square footage that could be,
I mean he just goes off on this crazy tangent and like,
like what kind of heard like an epiphany happening on there.
So I think,
um,
particularly teenagers said to me when they did it like,
oh,
I don't like this feeling.
I don't recognize it.
I was like,
yeah,
that's boredom.
So just like stick with it,
lean into it.
Um,
but it's however you kind of define it,
um,
it's as personalized as your homescreen,
I would say.
Anybody else?
All right,
well thank you so much for joining us and sharing.
Yeah,
it was a pleasure.
Um,
anybody thinks that,
I mean I really want to know,
like,
do you think this is total bullshit?
Like I really,
really like,
I'm really open to it.
Um,
cause I think,
you know,
I was at Powells last night in Portland and I was like,
oh,
I'm going to Google to tomorrow.
And some people in the audience were like,
I was like,
Whoa,
really?
Should I be nervous?
But then I had a lot of,
um,
like a guy from apple came up afterwards and was telling me about all these
great hacks that he has to like keep people from bugging him on his phone.
I was like,
dude,
you should tell us.
I didn't know that you could do like some of the things that you're telling me,
like we should all know about these little hacks because I think it would make
people feel a lot better about their tech use.
I mean,
I love my phone,
but I see that it really plays into some of my weaknesses.
My,
my,
I'm a human and I am deeply flawed and my phone knows it and it just knows how
to like bring it out in me.
So,
um,
so it's been a really interesting conversation that I'm having with people and,
and I'm really grateful for any feedback you can give me.
I really am.
So thanks again for having me.
I'm going to hang out.
If you have something and you're like,
don't want,
if you don't want to shame me in front of your colleagues or something like
that,
that's cool too.
[inaudible].